the united states stock market is
absolutely in shambles what am i talking
about the first half of this year we
posted the worst stock market
performance since 1970. ladies and
gentlemen this is the worst that stocks
have done in 50 years to go ahead and
start a calendar year the s p 500 is
already down 21 so far this year and
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies crashing
more than 50 percent but major tech
stocks alphabet apple facebook or meta
netflix and more losing at least 20
percent each and some of them doing even
worse
it took the stock market 161 days to
fall from its peak in january to a 20
decline in june
and of course the average time 245 days
in past bear markets and so many many
people think that maybe it's going to
turn around maybe we may actually get
some sort of relief but i don't know the
macro economic situation doesn't look
too hot we then have this quote from
edward moya where he says a global
central bank effort to fight inflation
is driving rising recession fears that
have given wall street the worst half of
the year since 1970. added volatility
from the final trading day of the
quarter is especially crazy because so
many investors are rebalancing their
portfolios with recession stocks now
naturally people keep an eye on the
day-to-day price movements because
there's so much volatility but over a
long period of time the american stock
market has done exactly what it's
designed to do keeps accruing value
because there's more corporate profits
and the dollar continues to be devalued
against these public equities but in the
short term it's been painful and it only
appears to be getting worse and worse
the first half of 2022 posted the worst
stock market performance since 1970
52 years of history we are living
through right now
now of course things that go down if
they don't go to zero they gotta recover
at some point right
maybe
keep your eye on the second half of the
year
a lot of people in the stock market are
hurting many people in other asset
classes hurting even more the federal
reserve says that they are committed to
continuing to tighten financial
conditions
and until the fed lets off their foot on
the gas i think that we're in for a
bumpy ride
the stocks
they're falling but that doesn't mean
that everyone's selling
just means that the prices have come
down
and of course
as we've seen over and over and over
again
stocks in the short term can be volatile
but over very long periods of time the
stock market only goes up into the right
at about a 45 degree angle because the
dollar is being devalued and in some
crazy way
stocks end up being a beneficiary of
that